we now know that blake shelton and gwen
stefani do not plan on getting married
before the new year
i can be happy anyway i would say i just
want my parents there at this point like
my parents wouldn't come to thanksgiving
because they're so scared so
um really would rather it not be a
coveted situation
like i would rather not have masks and
that kind of thing
so hopefully sometime uh this coming
year we can
find a window and get this wedding
planned but for now we don't even have
it
planned when or anything blake says his
engagement to gwen earlier this year was
quote
the saving grace of 2020 for me we were
stuck together for six months at one
point without
ever having a day apart and we've just
found that we don't ever want to be a
part
[Music]
well today gwen's got a lot to celebrate
last night on the voice she performed
her new single
let me reintroduce myself i haven't
released a single
outside of christmas and being on
amazing
country songs with blake shelton uh in
five years but i found gwen song on the
outtune shark
you're number one
next week is the two-part season finale
and the coaches
are already looking forward to some
family time the holidays will be
different for kelly
dealing with her divorce but she's
staying positive
hands down favorite food and drink for
the holidays
a pinot noir and or mulled wine i love
when i go to some like
some person's house well nobody's going
anybody's houses christmas
where um but and then i love pumpkin pie
oh with whipped cream
you